this is what you said you said what's so
special about me most women aren't
special well no I'm like seriously what
what do women bring in 2022 that is
special
do most women have a cookbook do most
women really know how to cater to a man
no are most women virgins on their
wedding day no so what do most women
bring in 2022 that is special but why is
it all about what we can offer why is it
always because because
when you're talking when you're trying
to sell a car if you're trying to get
married right then please I'm not saying
that women are cars it's just an analogy
but if you're trying to sell a car you
have to study the buyer and figure out
what the buyers want